think women in general care what men
want
yeah they do
what do you think
yeah what do you oh I don't think the
modern day woman does I think when you
find that woman that's a little bit more
mature and
still a bit cultured
um yeah we do care what I mean our men
want but the Modern Woman no they don't
care what do you think well people will
not give a till they get older than
lonely they really want a man then they
decide to investigate and find out what
a man wants I don't think they care so
what what do men want
um I'll as in a relationships that's set
in then let's say a wife she's looking
for a wife what does he want in a wife
what does he want her to do what does he
want her to act like he wants it to be a
nurturer he wants her to look after
house and home he wants to look after
him
um
and he wants yeah that's I think that's
what men want in a woman which is what
her job should be is which is to nurture
and look after the Homemaker house at
home for a man
how would she make a house a home what
are some examples cooking and cleaning
and
um it's women that women it's a women's
touch to a house that makes it homely
um
that's your Jennifer Pearl
um so can I have some specific examples
like because I always hear that make a
house and do a home like how
specifically would you make a house into
a home
um I think it's just little things that
men don't think of like
um like the organization standard like a
lot of men you go into their home it's
just very basic like I remember what I'd
accents like candles and cushions and
blankets and yeah but it makes dust
collectors it makes it feel more it
makes it feel more homely than it does
than just like a shell or something
okay
um can you name something that she
didn't say that you think men want
definitely like taking care of the
children as well
um
basically all the things you said is
what I would agree with but yeah the one
thing she didn't mention was taking care
of the children
um definitely makes it home
okay
what about you um I think nowadays men
are looking for like a partner so
someone that they can have like an
honest
um conversation with about work maybe
business ideas their feelings someone
that just kind of understands them and
doesn't judge them too much
do you think that's what men want
one thing yeah I think they were a lot
more obviously I want I think they want
someone's open sexually
um someone that's loyal funny
um clean yeah I think on all rounds are
everything you listed sounded like what
women want from men yeah because we both
want them same from each other now what
do you say what do you think
um I think one thing that you didn't no
one mentioned is fit fit yeah like BMI
skinny small tiny yeah but so maybe with
it maybe with a butt but a small one
sure they don't have a choice I think
they just want to hold They Don't Really
Care what's around the hall I mean I
think it depends like if a guy has a Jew
okay does Leonardo DiCaprio
date fat chicks or thin chicks
like average guys I know that's what I'm
saying when when the men have all the
choices in the world it's like the most
beautiful women in the world who do they
date the rich men yeah right the the
most handsome tall successful men in the
world who do they date the models that's
because society makes it known that
that's what is attractive and that's
what's known to be it's the fact that
they that's more attractive people are
respected more by people because that's
that's the standard that's been set but
if that was the case you wouldn't get
big women that get married if if that's
all men want is a skinny person
essentially
um well I mean there's always going to
be someone like I mean one out of three
men are having sex with anyone so
there's always going to be there's
always going to be someone but again I
think you can really see what men want
and like what do they do when the men
that have all the choice who do they
pick
yeah because that's that's the standard
look at George Michael when before he
came out as gay he was seen with models
because it wasn't known to be so what's
your I'm just kidding what's your
premise your premise is that they're
dating them because they're dating the
pretty models because society's telling
them that yeah they could have an
underlying fetish for someone but
they're not going to come out and do
that because Society doesn't deem that's
the type of person that you should be
with as a successful person no I I don't
think so I think like because I mean
being overweight that says something
about you you know it's like it's your
lifestyle choices so if you're in shape
why would you want to date someone
that's not because some people have have
uh have things for people that are of
different right but then but then when
they have the choice to date a fat chick
or a thin chicken they pick the thin
chick
wouldn't that indicate that men like
beautiful thin models yeah but it also
goes back to my point of that's what's
picked as a whole don't get me wrong
some people do like that that type of
body type however Society deems that
that's the type of person that's known
that you should be with because of your
stature and Calabar that doesn't mean
that that you some people will find
other body shapes attractive however
when you're in the Limelight if it were
to be of a bigger girl they're going to
get stick for it because why are you of
the fat chick how essentially how does
society shame that when we have
movements like body positivity for women
and not for men
he who said this name put there's no
movement for
um when he puts a TV for man because
anytime a bigger woman is on any social
media and receives pushback she has all
these women coming to her defense but we
can on a short man all day or a
broke man all day because I don't want
no scrub scrub is it like you see and as
well and Victoria's Secret who do they
have on the covers
they have the big chicks now
but it's I still not even though that's
the case you still have those people
that come in and say why are you
promoting and why are you advertising
for people to be overweight so it still
it still has a backlash too but it's
still seen as negative lizzo she gets it
all the time for Being for being big as
she said
I was about to say that
we don't I really don't understand years
and years and years ago
before you use football
I used to get state for being skinny
Slim
and all the all the big women are out
there
but then they were there was a change
because all the big women got all the
men they all slept around which they're
skinny women with low body counts
and now most of the fat women they're on
their own
and they're still fat
and I'm skinny yeah you fat women and
I'm skinny
and I'm loving it
I'm absolutely loving it because the
amount of slagging up I used to get for
being skinny but with the fat birds out
there saw the fat birds I'm glad that
you're still fat
because nobody really wanted the fat
birds the fat birds in back in the day
were good for shagging
that's what they're good for bouncing on
I mean me quite frankly it's quite clear
that I'm fat and I don't it doesn't
really bother now I said before your day
oh now
skinny birds when I'm happy
I'm not happy that it's coming when I'm
old do you know what I mean but I'm just
happy that it's come back again
that's skinny chicks I feel like it's
it's always been there but they've
always had us away all made us look
really anorexic like those models and
then that I think that's what it is they
went too far with the modeling and you
know the skinniness they were like
looking anorexic and then all of a
sudden they went from all those mother
to to skinny to now there's certain
clothes shops that I go into and I can't
buy clothes my size they don't start in
my size and if I do do my size they
start from like size eight to size 32.
why am I going to play the same price as
somebody's associated
they use more material than me no plus
size clothes are more expensive
yeah but if that shop does small sizes
then I should get a percentage of at
least half price because I'm half their
size
Auntie do you think it's society that
makes men
um the rich
successful man
deep models you think it's Society
telling them to do that no why do you
think they do it because they can who
wouldn't want to if there was a poor man
he wasn't successful and somebody said
oh you can get a model why wouldn't you
why would somebody successfully want to
go out of an ordinary person anyway
unless they were there with them from
the beginning and we could look at it
both ways I mean would you rather date
Chris Brown Chris Brown or what's his
name oh my God I can't think of his name
the the dude that was on Fresh
like
see I hate it when you get to a certain
point because people might actually see
it when you say their names
um
who's that guy with the curly hair from
the movie
I can't think of his name but I mean I
feel like it works both ways though like
I mean I just think in the people with
the most options tend to pick In-Shape
people on both ways you don't think
that's true
no well not at the moment and apparently
I bought that boards are the thing
that's in right now
is there a dad bod calendar
I wouldn't I have no look but
that builds it in
no well I see all over the Internet is
Dad buds at the moment because scissor
released a song I don't remember how it
goes but she was basically saying get
yours get yourself a big guy's basically
yeah
I don't think a big guy is a dad bought
though a dad board is someone that don't
work out is just don't look after
himself like because I think it's
difficult because some people they're
born overweight and big so I'm saying
nobody get born overweight no no no no
no okay obviously but as they grow into
toddler you know and I've got
experienced personal experience I've
seen it they're like they was born that
size and they raised that size like
Society is changing which I'm saying we
can't be so shallow to be like okay
someone's body the way they look like
it's all about that person what they're
attracted to so I'm saying yeah but we
can talk in general and so like in
general people are more attracted to
thinner people healthier people than how
about that healthier people people with
their BMI intact I don't care no baby
ain't born big and if they're born big
then by the time they start running
around they lose weight
they start losing weight no you do that
right before they're a beast and losing
weight anybody that's obese it's like a
discipline if a child's obese the mother
need the parents need locking up that
child should be taken away from them any
obese if you've got a child it's obese
they should give you a warning and if
you don't stick to the diet then you
should lose your job
that's my opinion but I think it's you
know we need to clarify the fact that
some guys and some girls do like bigger
girls or guys like I've dated chunky
guys I've got a little bit of a belly
whatever because it's not a big it's not
that big a deal you know it's a little
bit different when they're like really
really big to women and to men some men
like big girls it's it's usually because
they have no other choice okay
if you line up 10 fat chicks and 10 bin
chicks most men are gonna pick the thin
chicks over the fat chicks if both of
them want you know unless one's a freak
and he's a feeder
but it's like we talk about in general
we don't talk about it you know what I
mean like there's exceptions sure but
it's not just happened
um like come on
you're gonna pick this no I'm gonna give
you
Chris Hemsworth shirtless let's just
we're just gonna go who are you picking
this this one
or this one
I've been out bigger than that how would
that be bigger than that okay yeah
the great he had a great he had a great
personality I showed them this
versus versus
this I just picked Chris Hemsworth yeah
okay I'm gonna Read Super chats
um Auntie you can think of a question
for after okay yeah I'll give you I'll
give you a question privileges
yeah
yeah for being such a great a great
guest on Saturdays okay
Senor sticks why is there no such thing
as a mom bod
um something when you're saying big do
you when why are you saying big when you
mean fat and obese
maybe I'll start a scout and a Bradley
am I like bigger women but I still want
her fit I also want someone who can keep
her mouth shut loyalty Family Values I'm
a multi-millionaire and I'm fit and over
six feet tall silly sausage men just
don't a wife sweating on their kids
um take Queen the Lane Bryant chick in
white is in denial silver scale proud to
be a passport to buy by Western women
Danny advice needed if men are not
monogamous then what do women who cannot
handle that emotionally do stay single
um a bowl of Malik when I became Muslim
I had four children by three different
men and I've been married and widowed
and can choose to marry again anytime
Muslim men have loved my kids more than
their biological fathers anyone can
change culture find
do you think that men in the UK will
start leaving for other countries as the
passport Bros are not just black
Americans I'm Chris Rock a born-again
virgin is like trying to
fix a broken vase it just doesn't hold
water a scout and Bradley please bring
Mama Pearl back
um yeah when I go to the US I'm probably
going to do a one-on-one interview with
her with blessing lazy Prodigy
probability versus possibility H2O
mechanic um who's more desirable and has
more value a woman 44 with three kids
and has a body count of three or a woman
25 no kids but a body count of 50.
blessing you got to pick this one who
you picking a woman she's 44 with three
kids or a woman that's 25 or sorry a
woman 44 three kids body count of three
or a woman 25 no kids body count like
50.
yeah I think I'm I'm bye buddy camp I
know
damn it's a hard choice
I'm gonna I'm not gonna be a step daddy
so I'll tell you what I'll take the
other one
um sick Taiwanese feminization of the
Western countries in the EU us has been
overly negative in every way why do you
think we don't fight back against this
recovering nihilus I'm glad rental cars
exist but I never wanted to own one but
rental cars can be cleaned and renovated
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible